[Music]
hey Brian hey Laurence got an email here
I thought we weren't doing that yeah I
thought we were gonna do it the second
channel oh you got to subscribe to that
tg2 in the integration legends so
integration beryllium integration starts
now
hey Brian from email here from great
shadow legends they want a sponsor who
another no you can't say who you know
who they are you can playing their game
the one thing that you don't want to say
when you're about to massively endorse a
brand oh hey Brian yeah I've got an
integration here via email from red
shadow legends lordy brilliant once
another episode of true news genuinely I
can't say how grateful I am
they loved how many people from the show
last time went over to download the
brand-new RPG from these great guys and
the thing that everyone found when they
got over there was it's free what what
is right off right here you asked I
didn't do that so what is really awful
or there's a load of things it offers
Brian you can collect over 400 champions
you can assemble a team from 16 heroic
factions discover 13 spectacular
locations enjoy a fully voiced story
campaign now that's something that most
things on a games console don't even
have wow this is all just happening live
on the mobile phone Brian best of all
we're on it not as characters but I mean
coming soon surely I mean you do look a
bit like some of the character you very
sure obviously bloody handsome I've been
playing it for some time here looks like
it does installing them no no it says
shining in all right and what I love
most about it is that everyone can find
something for themselves so you know
some of it is that people have
collecting characters some of it is a
about the deep storyline some of it is
actually just the great graphics for a
mobile phone I wouldn't check the
reviews on the Play Store yeah cuz I was
a bit like yeah I know they're
sponsoring this but I just want to
double check what everyone else is
saying because there's one thing people
know about me Lawrence I really care
what people have got to say exactly and
300,000 almost perfect squibbon that's
why the great game is growing super fast
the highly anticipated new faction wars
feature is also now live classical
because I'm up got down on my calendar
these all know I know it's coming live
soon and obviously you get the new daily
log and reward
for the first 90 days in the game and if
you find me on the my nickname Lars cast
you might be able to be quick enough to
join my clan yeah it's probably gonna
fill up pretty quick I'm pretty sure
it's on the way to full already Bryan so
oh you've got a full clan baby hey so
what are you waiting for go to the video
description click on the special links
and if you're a new player you'll get a
hundred thousand silver one energy
refill 50 gems and one free champion can
I just be clear though yeah
if you don't click on that link you are
actually depriving me of making more
true news episodes on podcast so click
on the link yeah yeah yeah like all
jokes aside being dead ass seriously I'm
not this isn't for the read no I need to
pay the [__] bills these guys are
literally keeping the lights on right
now that Brian would you take a look at
this badass champion executioner and all
this treasure will be waiting for you
here can I just say though with the
treasurer thing yeah I need try I need
to be paid jump on the game play that
for a while enjoy it and you know when
you're playing that I've just helped
Jordy pay the [__] bills yeah um I
need that yeah and not only that Brian
but hurry up because the rewards are
only relevant for 30 days you want to
know what I enjoy most about the game
Brian tell me Lauren well sometimes it's
making my hero's power levels sort of go
up other times it's I'm knocking new
skills and abilities I suppose you're
more of a tactical strategy guy I like
the girl for the power play domination
and the great thing is you played for
five minutes or five hours completely
free so head over there links in the
description get all the great rewards
that we mentioned to fill you're in the
video jump on it turned into the honey
plays raids play raid top of the news
today Brian young woman who claims
famous Irish sports are sexually
assaulted er was chatting to him before
alleged attack now there's some CCTV
footage that's been put out there into
the police's grasp and apparently it
pictures the two walking to a car around
the same time that she alleges there was
an assault I would endure whoever could
be Lawrence does it serve where the
police off from it says they're from
Crumlin in Dublin which also sounds like
a Snoop Dogg lyric on what poi this
isn't funny
it's worrying we worry about the road
that certain Irish sports stars are
going down we're not talking about
ROI or robbie keane are we there any
other sports stars from Ireland Martin
O'Neill it's definitely not Martin
O'Neill my money would be on the woman
to beat Martin O'Neill off big-time
she'd beat the [__] out of that little
glasses you call that a [__] of penis
notorious oh really yeah completely
unrelated event
Ludi elbow calm have released a report
about a certain Irish sports star called
Conor McGregor I know of this sports
star he's bummed from a club after
accusations that a woman was forced into
an SUV with a teammate okay sounds
painfully similar but very different
yeah because it's a two unrelated well
it's Conor McGregor it one's an unnamed
a response a possibly Martin O'Neill
exactly yes inside early important
witnesses who saw McGregor's entourage
force a woman into a car outside of Los
Angeles celebrity hotspot Delilah so
this is in Le yes the whole other place
Sabine McGregor and a group of friends
were being rowdy at an establishment not
a crime no McGregor picked up a woman
who was working bottle service put her
over his shoulder the witnesses said
that McGregor plus the woman ah another
member of the entourage who then carried
her to an SUV that was parked outside
natural and normal behavior in the
modern society I don't know what to
believe anymore do you know what I mean
there's not much mud [__] come out about
McGregor I don't even know the witness
said the woman eventually came out with
the car looking and I caught rattled
rattled can me and I mean shamian yet
shaken or if you're from Newcastle
rattled mean is being [__] six ways
from Sunday Charlie Ward friend of Conor
McGregor and Bellator fight at all a
news outlet he was making out with the
staff female and a manager looked inside
the car and asked if the woman was being
held against her will
Ward claimed he thought this was a joke
and not the manager started yelling and
threatening to call the police
Ward further claimed that the staffer
made it known that she was here on her
own accord so this is really nothing to
do with Conor McGregor just like the
first floor one thing that is about
Conor McGregor is he's called out
Frankie Edgar not like Twitter frankly
Edgar former champion however fights to
weight classes below light weight these
days strange one I don't get it they
said Dana white make the fight happened
my purse the charity all of it hundred
percent of it so it much thought
yeah he donated a percentage of his
whiskey to the first responders Fair
Play
it's as if he's trying to distill his
conscience in some way he probably
misjudged that though Jeremy because I
don't think he expect the proper 12 to
sell quite as many bottles just arts
women even about their meet and greet on
the tour donate everything from their
charity something you regretted it what
you need to do in future is well how
much money you've got at the end of it
then donate the money don't tell people
at the store cuz then you've got to be
held away yeah exactly and I may never
do all the money always just say a
percentage you see in December he wants
to fight make er happen the fact that
both fighters are out there saying let's
do this I mean it's not the fight I won
from McGregor but [__] it if there's a
reason to get him in the cage let's say
yeah if it doesn't happen there's a lot
more going on in McGregor's life than
he's letting on oh if you're on Twitter
saying this Sutton your line it doesn't
happen you're a bullshitter it so sorry
yeah cuz DIY has no reason and not make
this fight happen now they've both said
yes on Twitter why would you not while
we're on fight and obviously we've
covered the ksi logo and fight a lot
we're gonna be doing loads more content
for it but a lot of people are coming
out calling it a cringefest calling it
silly and two clowns out there you know
doing the press conference and all of
that we've just had our fourth fight I'd
die in the last four months Patrick Day
who had a good record very open come and
fight general I mean in the prime of his
life I think it was 27 years old he won
like 60 in fights you'd only been
stopped once before never being like
knocked out not though has his first bad
knockout and then dies recently looking
at the way he was punished it wasn't
like it was anything I haven't seen
every single week in fight in UFC in
boxing it happens all the time I'm just
quite sick of people devaluing the act
of getting in the ring like I don't I've
got no problem if people don't like Jay
Jay and Logan that's fine like the
showmanship is not for everyone people
call it cringe-worthy that's fine when
these lads get in the ring be absolutely
sure that they're gonna put their
[__] bodies on the line and this is
actually real there is no head gods you
are going to see two people who are
going for the [__] kill people do die
in boxing because I've spent time with
Logan and JJ recently and I've spent a
lot of time with them in general and I
feel like I know them quite well
I'm like yeah you [__] you don't
actually realize like what's going on
here to a lot of people just taking this
is some sort of joke yeah they're taking
it very seriously taking it extremely
yeah when you see a young kid lose his
life to this sport it's like this isn't
[__] football me this isn't like a
charity football match something bad
could happen gin and I mean so you know
rest in peace - Patrick Day this is
another [__] this isn't a joke as
serious as a [__] get in sport and
it's just tragic when these young kids
lose their lives like that you know what
I mean yeah doing what they love in the
build-up to it there's a lot of
interviews a lot of interest in both of
the fighters how do you think JJ looks
that isn't like normal to Jimmy he looks
like a man now well he does but also he
looks like a young man in a roomful of
savages who he knows he has to learn
from when I watch this interview I like
his attitude is spot on there but that's
a student a true yes true yeah I mean
I've been waiting and waiting to get to
Vegas because I know this is when the
real work comes in I know this is where
so much boxing knowledge is here and I'm
able to just take everything I need to
take and literally just destroy a logo
with her I will show Jo 25 he reminds me
of and I don't mean always bring things
back to me right but you gonna say money
but it reminds me of a time where when I
first went offshore like wide ideas yeah
there's a humbling feeling when you're
around people who are they got better
than you at everything where you are
just absorbing every single thing that
is smart and taking it in exactly like
you need to be [__] sharp on your
toes whatever anyone tells you do it
whatever they say take it in like he is
gonna be like a [__] sponge in that
Mayweather gym for the next few weeks
like YouTube Instagram all the [__]
funds it all means nothing now like it
it's it's him and Logan in a ring
everything else is [__] and that's
the one thing I mean when our interviews
come out the one thing that I think
really comes across is we interviewed
them both last time and it's like going
from boys to men in that year yeah I
think about this fight once a day at
least and it's the best wank he'll have
all day
I keep racking my brains over who's
gonna win and this is the thing when our
interviews come out
I think after each podcast people will
be like he's winning
or he's when like that's where I felt
because the confidence is so strong with
ball for them I think we're getting the
defining winner for sure oh yeah I think
what's gonna happen is one of them is
gonna clearly have learned more than the
other
usually in rematches III expect to see
that because they saw young in their
boxing knowledge yeah it's the one who's
absorbed the most is gonna win and to be
fair to JJ we're looking at him here
he's in the [__] mirror with a gym
that's a good sign yeah if you ever
needed to absorb information on anything
this is like going to [__] university
and absolute for a whole month
that's exactly what it is yeah it's not
freshers week for him though terribly if
Lazos freshers week was only thing they
go off yeah wild time wild times just
reading in the library while we're on
boxing there's a youtuber who I'd be
watching for quite some time now
Lawrence and I never know whether it's a
character whether it's real I think
there's some there's definitely some of
it is real he might be one of the
wildest [__] on YouTube because
if you're gonna troll the sidemen yeah
don't pick professional boxers
apparently he was told by Anthony Joshua
recently to get the [__] out of his gym
and here's what happened a JPEG at the
start of a video is some banging music
though ah yeah you know I'm telling
Joshua was trying to bully me the other
day you know he was trying to really put
it on me the other day
Joshua let me tell you I can I was in
the engl gym game interview with kick a
lot I'm convinced that this is a real
story by the way let's just analyze
what's happening in the frame here he
always drinks rose' was his thing it's
strange because he actually Arnold's for
a sponsorship deal the things he says
even echo Falls wouldn't sponsor him and
I sat down on one side of the gym and
Joshua was on the other side of the gym
he was like looking at me like that and
anyway my lot and then I went ah
I've got see him as keep looking at me
and then I started texting this woman
who is one of society's reject and then
I looked up and I seen Joshua or walking
towards me and I sat down and he stood
there and I was looking up at him and he
said to me what did you say about me in
your videos
he's fake and he's just laughing at
Graham not and [__] jokes being all
media-friendly immediate rain stay home
boy I'm not in the national treasure
back off you can be a national treasure
instead of [__] Joe it's merely so I
said what did I say and then he said get
out my Jim and I wanted to smack him you
know I wanted to smack him you know of a
lucky punch on the gods compunction or
you know in the streets I've knocked out
three woman's so that'll be the point
there where you wonder whether it is a
character see you there I don't know but
keep watching in the street someone bein
like Mayweather
tbe and free and how in the streets
Joshua try not bully me find funny come
work out what the what the end joke is
like what's there it's just his little
like isms that I think he believed me
yeah keeps using lines she looks all
right don't you those tattoos have taken
off on being probably a 8 out of 10 down
to a 6 out of 10 but you know if I was
in a nightclub and she came up to me I
wouldn't say that was tattoo use a
horrible tattoos of taking you down a
few levels you want to get them removed
ASAP because they're [__] horrible
you're not saying yeah they're nice yeah
where did you get them don't they
I like him so men tell women anything to
get a [__] often thai-boxing TV he's
just a funny [__] you not all the time
you know he sometimes he crosses the
line but don't we all in a way I don't
know if we put this in out JJ is a good
friend calyx just broke up with his
girlfriend yeah and I know I
deliberately didn't watch it cuz I
thought we'd laugh at it I'm true noot
sorry we'd watch it on true news I've
not known calyx very well but it made me
sort of liked him a lot
this guy loves this girl right I've met
them both together they're cute lovely
come across really well you can tell
he's a good person by the way he had
deals with this [__] yet and today live
on BBC we have the breaking news from
Sarah Callas she's trying to play down
she's trying to make it look like it's
got small numbers she's saying it's on
BBC you can see when emotionally you're
not ready or deal with something so you
just do anything yeah five years
recently we just weren't making each
other happy anymore and we've done the
old layout we thought we've got
everything we need out of this time to
move on you're such a good we're not
getting any more out of it [__] off yeah
we've rinsed this for all it's worth
I'm getting emotional love I'll endure
going [__] hell we can't even rerun
those yeah who can make up their own
assumptions from Twitter and Instagram
posts where it's just the block of text
whereas if you see us together today we
hope that you can see that we do still
love each other what a mature young one
what a lovely young no oh yeah I think
the way he's thought about this is
spot-on we just both had Leia
I don't show on camera I'm just here to
insane you guys and we'll just keep it
at that and I just try and make the best
videos that I possibly can
it's been a crap 18 months I [__]
respect him for admitting that because
yeah what happens is when you're a
youtuber or an entertainer of any kind
but particularly with YouTube because
you've got a bit on camera so regularly
is if you're having a really [__] year
or 18 months as he said you feel like a
bit of a fraud on camera leave me you
feel like who my [__] kid now I'm not
[__] happy I've had those feelings
and the fact that he's putting that out
there is very good it's difficult when
you break up in public obviously because
people still put together they can pay
your part not being incentive yeah five
years brothers
a lot of options out there No Wow okay I
thought you were gonna make a plea to
her so thank God you didn't that's fair
enough
no yeah what you're basically saying is
this play more fishing this time but I
love a guy I'm not the type of guy that
just go after an ex-girlfriend of over
me I'm just in the options are open car
Wow are you making oblique Alex your
options are open here buddy
if you know what I mean thank you
Laurence but no I'm sure he's more than
well I'm just saying life is a game and
now is your time to play that game
mother rohnke roll the gate I roll the
foot not the gray eyes nice can why'd
you have to make everything about Hawaii
Valentin why are you leaving why you
would try and always inject your penis
come here and give us a lot of football
now not really football you said it was
footballers and their wives
starting with Paul Gascoigne aka Gaza
he's been found not guilty sexual
assault and also assault by beating well
I'll read some of the things that came
out in the in the courtroom when I was
playing I wasn't the slimmest and I was
called fat my niece and nephews were
called fat and we lost one of them Jay
took drink and drugs bless him when I
heard that noise fat anyone who gets at
Neum are automatically protected God's
going demonstrates to the jury what his
speech is like without his dentures
which he tells the court he didn't have
enough that day the jury hears that this
is why the 52 year old speech may have
been slurred on the train because
obviously they're trying to find a
reason Mikey slurring his words I can't
think of another but not for a known
alcoholic my England international TOEFL
is he was drinking beer on the train he
had a few cans maybe three or four just
to be clear an ex-alcoholic just having
three four cans on the try a highly
plausible situation he also says he
can't drink gym after a recent operation
as it makes him spew the court heard he
had a drink the defense told the jury
but he wasn't out of control his
intentions were good but deployed in the
wrong way kissing is what mr. Gascoigne
what do you mean that can't be maybe too
emotional but it doesn't make it sexual
no I just I just walk around in public
and go got that person looks like I need
help I must kiss them a kiss according
with the defense Michelle hire a woman
law
nice one yes can be anything from a
mother kissing her child to two people
getting married or from a teammate when
you score one of the greatest goals for
England against Scotland that year or 96
the father his solicitor I would think
to implant that in do the jury's mind oh
you'd hope that you're a natural about
what Gaza did you what I find amazing is
we're comparing kissing a strange total
stranger yeah on the train on the train
who does not want to be near him I think
when comparing that to a kiss from a
mother of a child to use of getting
Murray absolutely natural and beautiful
known each other their whole life yeah
and also him scoring a goal with his
teammates I was comparing that was the
prosecution who came up with mr.
Gascoigne
mr. Lionel T in mr. Gascoigne lied and
lied alive from the start he lied up
until and during giving evidence in
court mr. Gascoigne has been lying
through his teeth
whichever teeth they were at the time
right which was a great line from the
day basically it just seems like there
wasn't quite enough evidence to nail him
on the fact that he basically put it on
at all straight and Johnnie was pissed
off as a football fan and as a Newcastle
lad
III wanted defend Gaza the signs are
good name jacy's he's been found not
guilty of sexual assault but that
doesn't mean he's innocent if you know
what I mean right he's still being a
[__] so in the legal sense he absolutely
is in a very literal sense [__] yes we
were - Rebecca vodi
who may be guilty may not be right to be
honest with you they're not that's what
you know all right just a recap on this
[__] Coleen Rooney put out a
statement and which sort of she got
nicknamed wagga thought Christy because
of the way she detailed how someone had
been sharing stories from a private
Instagram account she couldn't put a
finger on who it was she thought I've
got a sneaky suspicion that it's this
one person she turns everyone else off
and only allows one person to see them
and then the stories carry on coming out
in the newspapers and she at the end
reveals it was Rebecca
Vardy
Mira Parvati what she knows her [__]
stories because Jamie won't give me any
money yeah I've always found it strange
that Rebecca Vardy was so desperate to
be famous like when she went on I'm a
celebrity I'm like no no you're not a
celebrity you're just wife of a
footballer me out of hair should be or
not you do nothing you are nothing to do
with the public you're not famous you're
not famous you're trying to become
famous by being on a TV show why are you
doing that because you crave fame and
what do people do hoo-wah Fame hoes
these sell stories to newspapers I'm
afraid now Coleen Rooney from 16 years
old being with Wayne Rooney yes has
always sheltered herself from the public
I obviously should be in photographs
because she was a superstar football as
wife from very early on and make no
mistake about the Wayne Rooney biggest
England goal scorer of all time
Manchester United record goalscorer
superstar Jamie Vardy was someone who
sort of appeared lay are on the scene
later on in life and it wasn't never the
same level of fame that way and Rooney
was exposed to for many many years
Colleen never courted that it was just
in our life ever and when she was
humiliated by way and she conducted
herself with absolute dignity I thought
the whole time - George a character I
looked at that to judge Rebecca Voorhees
character who the minute Jamie Vardy has
one good [__] season faster she's on
I'm a celebrity you know the type of
people were dealing with here I feel
sorry for Kelly and she can't even trust
her own friends
although killeen after a while is also
not divorce Wayne Rooney in those kind
of thing well that's I think that's her
decision or absolutely and that and also
he's the father of her children
absolutely Rebecca Vardy is just some
random there she is what we see what
Trish's been up to C sharp eight assists
right I wonder what Trish husband up do
or who's been up Trisha no one these
days she's given it she's not pregnant
is she
we're about to find out she was a
[__] man two days ago let's start
with the [__] she was transitioning
right I don't think she was transition
well she was saying she was an enum she
was a man inside here in there in there
out here because she has giant fake tits
do you wanna know how to get views on
YouTube you don't have to put out good
content these are the type of
things you need to say right transgender
next day apology now I'm questioning
next day then a morning routine obvious
only throws in a morning routine also
think is right after that was scheduled
after the previous week you know all of
these right I don't think how can this
person have a morning routine I can copy
learn I don't look at them and think
they're on really doesn't know what's
going on yeah and they're likely morning
routine wake up that was 20 minutes
borderline personality disorder don't
joke about this yeah thing the Trisha
shared in Shane Dawson right I was like
everyone I mean I was that guy from for
24 and then hi dressed as a joker and
then early pregnancy acne we're not
dealing with a sane person yeah I said
like a couple of weeks ago they played
over speaking our mind can I just say I
completely take that back absolutely
you've just exploited every minority or
anyone who's in any troubled situation
she'll tag you in the video so next week
she's gonna be a terrorist
this woman is not safe at this point and
Zac Efron had to get into the mind of
Ted Bundy well Brian if that depressed
you then this is gonna be pretty hot
women no Brian I thought I'd show you
farming simulator 19 an adventure number
one this is episode three by the way
I've skipped a couple of episodes in
[__] to you Joseph no no Brian this
is farming simulator this is a
real-world a simulator of farming work
who's probably some [__] teenager
although you go ladies and gentlemen
boys and girls of the logging community
here I'm farming simulator 19 this is
your boy pjl daily comin at you I don't
know what's more pathetic the fact that
this has got six likes or dislikes the
father took more dislikes than the six
licensed the farming community is
notoriously [__]
we are going to e camp the biggest
little the biggest what these long gaps
is not he's not watching the biggest
he's watching the biggest log load that
we've ever attempted this isn't any dig
at you by the ways yeah if there's one
thing you know I love it's a good log
line although there's no woman involved
in this sadly stacked on top of what we
already got what's going on better
what up boys how's it goin by the way I
didn't watch this video before oh it's
just hoping it would be good I just saw
a farming simulator and I click like
let's say they're working it's sort of
some sort of car rental place and
they're just desperate to get home so
they can plant bomb simulator just go
and work on a farm in I mean [__] your
job off won't work on an actual you can
do this for real you know when you play
initially I play fortnight I think okay
I can't go out in public I can't jump
out of a plane or a fine bus and go to
people right you can do this you can
literally go and find a farm and
literally do this no this was a farm
similar where you've got to do
unrealistic things I would get it it's
all of a sudden that you can make cows
with pigs yeah things like you can't or
multiple farms are build a huge empire
but all he's doing is the dog work
he's literally doing the most basic [__]
on a simulator what is the world coming
I've won eight logging I'm gonna try to
literally grab all these guys think I
can do it yeah I'm gonna go crazy
let's go boil what five and one go you
guys should be able to operate heavy
machinery like this guys this is crazy
I had a couple on the way home from work
and now I'm going crazy I'm tank tops
had a huge update that came out uh
what's today today so Saturday it came
out and let me tell you what a
difference that he's made on this on
this game as far as logging goes
unbelievable
let me tell you what a difference you
look at how slow this this is what by
the way this guy's walking around as if
the farmer himself over what he's trying
to do is get a good angle yeah so that
we can see yeah the logging commenced a
lot when I game Wow I play on
battlefield I want to know what it feels
like to be a soldier
sniping trying to kill people to not be
killed I'm on rocket League we're
playing football with actual cause I
want to do things I can never do yeah
listen to this look at the excitement
this is ridiculous that look at that
look at my look at where I'm standing
look how much taller
look at that than me that is the biggest
blog post full art room I've ever seen
that's unbelievable
I don't speak about women's naked
breasts like this look amazed
unbelievable this is another food
reviewer we've unearthed the gem here
yeah guys go head over to five one eight
long if you've got anything you want us
to talk about on true news don't forget
the Twitter or Instagram or Instagram
link is in the description blow I've
nearly over tape and Lauren sub leave
all you want I'm on 82 now so you can go
hit that hit that what loss Costello
said CAS TC over there that's a great
content story see if kiss I'm chasing me
down eyeball or true Geordie official or
who's gonna hit hundra K first [__]
girls subscribe to the true Giada
YouTube channel thanks for watching
we'll see you later
he's gone he's gone don't forget to do
some logging yeah